last time I met you I have an
anti-racism non-profit I remember very
vividly world because it got me when I
left you went after me I remember
[Music]
at the end of the day what I do for a
living is you use words and content to
change people's perceptions when you
think about the way that everyone is a
stunning majority of people here come
from insecure unhappy places and enough
words and content was put in their head
by me and others that changed our
perseverance you said it's marketing
it's branding they got bad information a
double down I'll be hitting at it the
U.N the actual United Nations I didn't
even know they had a music arm it's
called the international music Council
they reached out to my non-profit they
said I saw what you're doing on social
seems like we're aligned I've met with
the president of the international music
Council and we're trying to do our work
man dude I can't thank you enough I'm so
proud of you thank you I give a lot of
ideas but a lot of people don't do
anything about it I'm so proud of you